hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan
and h foley
yes sir hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's
favorite new podcast this is are you
garbage the show where we sit down with
your favorite comedians and fun if they
grow up classy
or if they're absolute trash i'm your
host stage foley coming at you on a nice
chilly rainy fally day here in new york
[ __ ] city alive and well in the east
village
here in the gas digital studios in the
big studio
could not be more excited my co-host
coming at you from right next to me
all right he's a good kid he's a good
[ __ ] gang you know the drill the next
time you're reaching for a best pal
you go ahead and you make it a kippy
which is going to be a t-shirt coming
very soon and i think you're going to
like to design i'm custom crafting this
with one of the best artists in uh in
europe kevin james ryan everybody hey
thanks for flubbing three words in that
last sentence of yours
uh what's up everybody thanks so much
for tuning in uh as always please make
sure you rate review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube you can
subscribe there as well
and also gas digital network if you want
to sign up get the whole catalog of
shows
yeah uh you can sign up use promo code
ayg we get to wet our beaks a little bit
you love that money you save a couple of
bucks we make a couple of bucks it's a
win
[ __ ] win yeah thanks a lot guys
absolutely and gang we could not be more
excited to have our incredibly special
guest with us here today
another got a hot one requested
comedian on the podcast today this kid's
an earner i'll tell you that right now
he is a very successful stand-up
comedian and actor
as a stand-up he has appeared on the
tonight show with jay leno
he has his own comedy central presents
comedy underground with david tell
last comic standing conan comedy
knockout
the tonight show with jimmy fallon this
week at the comedy cellar
all right as an actor he has appeared in
inside amy schumer
aka wyatt cenac and a [ __ ]
scene stealer oh and the summer [ __ ]
blockbuster
the king of staten island but most
importantly
he is a part of the gas digital family
he has an incredible podcast
right here on the network that i know
all of you are fans of and if you're not
you gotta [ __ ] check it out
it's called no disrespect the big
question where his mind today is he
garbage
i'm saying no because every time i'm
around him i get the feeling he wants to
hurt me
so i think he's got a really good sense
and judge a character
give it up for the one the only mr mike
vecchio everybody hey
thank you guys for having me in to um
test whether i'm garbage or not
dude i like you guys foley and ryan it's
like rogue cops
yeah yeah cornering me fatso and the
baldy is what we call it
we made some mistakes we're trying to
get it all back trying to get it right
well like i told you before i'm a big
fan of the podcast i'm ready to be put
to the test i made sure i got plenty of
sleep last night
i did my stretches and my mental acuity
exercises so i'm ready for anything you
have to throw them at me
mayo no ketchup no any kind of those
white trash things those condiments that
you throw
at me i'm already ready to say no grey
poupon yes
oh yeah let me make the decision for you
easier okay
i come confrontational i come
confrontational
it gets
[Laughter]
i know you guys like an arc dylan went
to the we went to the same high school
did you guys know that he had mentioned
community
i don't know if you realize that or not
kratom over here
91 and 15 in this [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] i do want to say you [ __ ]
stole that scene in [ __ ] the king
man [ __ ] awesome was that one of your
that's one of your bits i believe right
or is that something well i improv the
beauty about judd is he'll put you in a
scene
and then there's lines but he'll let you
improv it and he'll give you a bunch of
takes and it's it's it's fantastic it
was it was that was like one of the joys
to see you get that like as i was
watching and then they kept coming back
to what i'm like
it was fantastic and pete was very
generous in that too he just let me roll
so that was a very classy thing he just
did there yeah and i'm saying
that there's no doubt in my mind that
you're classy there's no there's no
yeah but but you're still gonna ask me
the questions of course we'll see if
we'll see if there's any dirt there for
sure but what he said when he said
that's the thing about judd
yeah yeah it's a classy segway that's
the thing about you nice you guys are
being both good cops right now
i'm waiting for the best you're bad for
both of us
you're psychologically trying to trick
me into relaxing and i'm just getting
the phone book in here now
and then you're going to hit me do you
have an above ground pool which is a
sure sign that you're waiting oh yeah
he's got one oh yeah he's got one that's
half they dug it they dug it a little
lower so it's half above
build a deck around there you dive right
in mike walk right off the patio dive
right in but you can't dive it's only
three feet so
do a cannonball it's a gentleman it's
more of a puddle i think is it long
island
no outside of philly oh okay we talked
about this a little briefly you do have
jersey roots though
i lived in philly for eight years and i
taught there but i don't have anyone but
you didn't grow up there yeah
okay interesting did you start comedy
there because you were i remember you
being a fit like i remember back in the
day
is no longer uh you know in business but
uh
i i think it's interesting that dives
that you said like it's like a
cannonball white trash that
is actually classy sure if you can pull
one off yeah you know the different ways
to leap into the water
the trashiest would be the can opener
yeah the one leg because there was only
few guys that could do that very well
they were always underage smokers they
were cut off
they had like a really thin chest with
like a little bit of chest hair
they were banging somebody's mom but
when they're describing everybody who
hangs out at the wawa yeah
but when they show up at that pool man
they got [ __ ] athletic abilities but
the thing that made it trashy is like
they were they
that was their time to shine yeah you
had to convince them
like hey greg come over do the can
opener like really get it going and they
they reveled in it what does a can
opener look like if i might be it's the
one leg
one leg you might know it as a cherry
bomb all right two as well
okay it's uh aka cherry bomb that's
really
the belly flop also is a white trash of
course
you know a belly flop contest if you've
ever been to
or participated in a belly flop contest
so you can't come back i mean it's one
step away from suicide
let's just really be honest but the can
opener shows athletic ability
yeah that is when people peek there was
that guy that could do that
all right there was uh the guy i knew a
kid he was the biggest dirt ball in our
town
but he could hold himself sideways on a
[ __ ] like a street pole wow
yeah there was always single family
single single parent family
yeah do weird [ __ ] like that had a mini
bike zipping around i had a mini bike
i think you guys are talking about core
strength right now
this guy shines you're a buff i'm losing
weight
you do keep it tight you have a strict
diet you keep it tight well i was
on a diet and i i mean we can get into
diet if you want to i don't know if this
counts
big but uh i was on the i've been
experimenting with a bunch of stuff but
i finally figured it out now in
quarantine okay more excited about it
great what is it what are you doing a
keyboard it's a keto version it's a keto
version of intermittent fasting
so i'm doing keto but but i would just
my problem is overeating so i would just
do keto but then i would just eat yeah
and then that didn't help me at all so
it's like
and i i refused to do intermittent
fasting for a long time because i
wrestled and i suffered when i had to
cut weight really bad
he complains about it i honestly people
don't believe me
but i and i would never change it for
the world i loved it it was an
unbelievable experience
uh i honestly feel like that has that
[ __ ] me up and [ __ ] up my
relationship with food
and i honest every time i walk up a
flight of stairs i think about that
because we used to have to run these
stairs over and over and over and over
again right i think i was already [ __ ]
up but wrestling
implanted that in my mind this is a lot
of suffering my friend greg warren do
you know
yeah yeah of course he's a [ __ ]
fantastic uh was a really really good
wrestler he was an all-american
and uh that's right he does have
cauliflower yeah he won't get on the
scale now
it doesn't matter where doctor's office
physical he's like nope
and he will get into a verbal thing with
the doctor
i'm not getting on a [ __ ] scale dude
he's like just closure i think no no no
holy [ __ ] so let's get into the uh the
origin
story of mike vecchio here another thing
too i just want to point this out all
right if i may
sidebar there there's i don't think
there's gonna be anywhere to go on this
i have never seen him where his hair
didn't look exactly [ __ ] like that
was like a cartoon can you get a haircut
every three days i believe the word
you're looking for is equidistant
shaped up on both sides i do that for
geometric reasons as much as anything
guys i got so much styling he's just big
into angles
how many how often do you get a haircut
i cut it every two weeks but i caught it
i learned how to cut it in college my
roommate james burrell shout out to
i give him credit every time james shout
out to james
everybody's getting a shout out showed
me how to poke in a jersey
from judd he's a lawyer in new york now
uh and uh we went to college he was a
maryland state champ he was [ __ ]
really tough and uh a lawyer now and he
taught me how to do it in college so i
would do it mess up and he would just be
there to like fix it and he did that
until i figured it out
so that's how that's cuts his own hair
and he keeps how do you get the back
i cut it with a mirror i don't trust
myself it's like a magic trick
there's a lot of mirrors
same thing when i take my pants off a
lot of smoking here
i'm always amazed by that especially
these days i always hear
like women say like you know like the
guy pulled his dick out right away
that's my last [ __ ] move
yeah i don't think that's happening so
much anymore yeah i think that's for the
record
yeah um boca raton florida boca raton
florida well
i have a weird story because i was born
in youngstown ohio which is like rust
belts
yeah yeah that's like that's the epitome
of like blue collar like young town
youngstown yeah
so my grandfather on my father's side
had a family business
they had a mushroom growing and canning
operation that started out as
started out of spaghetti sauce couldn't
compete with ragu and some of the other
big names
are you being serious absolutely what
you that's like that's like an italian
superhero
story who's killing us we'll get them
[ __ ] now
hey grandpa what about these mushrooms
all right
put them in a can so you started a
canning operation that's great
candy mushrooms awesome oh he pivoted
big canned mushroom fan i just want to
say even now
canned mushrooms and canned potatoes are
huge at the foley house well they're all
impor the imports now but back when they
were back when it was still
still american yeah so um goddamn
chinese
it was uh canning operation and then he
added a growing operation so it was a
growing yeah
he's a mover and shaker it's a mover and
shaker immigrant yeah
and uh my so my aunt and uncle ran the
uh
under him ran the canning uh side and my
father was on the growing operation side
but they had a contentious relationship
so in 1981 the relationship blew up
my father was like i'm not staying here
with my family and we moved to boca
raton florida
we stayed in boca raton florida from 81
to 85
86 and then we moved back to
uh youngstown because they decided to
give it another try because the business
was failing without my
father gotcha two more years there i
spent eighth and ninth grade
in youngstown uh going to high school
learned to wrestle in ohio
great wrestling in ohio of course and
then uh it blew up again
and we moved back to boca raton florida
for my sophomore junior and senior year
how bad did that suck going
from [ __ ] boca raton to youngstown
actually believe it or not i wanted to
move back really cause you were there
already that was like your that
they were that was your roots a little
bit well it was different for me because
i was playing pop warner football uh
organization tech boca jets and i would
have to go to jets i would have to it
was contact football yeah
yeah big back in the pound 80 pound
football league 80 pound football league
he put the shoulder pads on him like
this big we were [ __ ] hitting there
yeah i remember
talking about me going back to high
school he's going pop warner i [ __ ]
wanted to take putting a helmet on
people 11 men get into the [ __ ] ball
swarming defense
what was your jersey number in position
i played uh
first year when i was nine i played nose
nose guard
nine year old nose guy number fifty nose
guard
yeah he did have two pounds on the other
guys two cycles of roids a month
oh i love it nine year old with back
hair [ __ ] killing people
that's [ __ ] awesome dude my neighbors
used to play football i never we never
played my
we were in a football household but my
neighbors played pop warner young
i met like those those families those
dads were all carpenters and they were
all
they were roofers dude my father was way
in and i'm like a kid got paralyzed the
year before i started playing when i was
eight
and uh i go dad a guy got paralyzed
the year before you know my father said
he's like make sure you're in shape
tackle with good form keep your head up
do your neck do your neck exercise
that's fine like you'll be all right
make sure you tackle with good form
don't tackle with your head down you'll
be good that kid was an [ __ ] yeah who
knows what he did he had a gum
that's wild but i remember being so
afraid i'd be like i remember
the girl the girl next door played with
the boys she would lay dudes out
and i remember being so scared like
you're going to go out there and just
tackle but i was petrified
seeing a football helmet up close as a
child it might as well be in the [ __ ]
space suit it just looks so
thick and heavy and [ __ ] look like it
hurt that was not for me
so i did that and so that was my then i
graduated from high school
i placed in states and uh wrestling in
uh high school
and then i went to florida in florida
okay and then i went to college at uh
penn state and i wrestled there for a
little while
and then maine pennsylvania nice and
then i moved to
playing sports at [ __ ] that's how you
do it altoona's got a good program
that's right man altoona has a bad guy i
moved to philly when i graduated because
i was dating a girl from philly in
college so i moved to philly in 95
and then stayed there till 2003 then
moved to new york started comedy in
2000.
he came up here for comedy yeah
absolutely yeah i came here for comedy
is the canning operation still in
business or not it's all sold it's all
done yeah and before your father left it
had gotten
it was a pretty successful company it
got successful yeah because one of their
their main clients were uh
you don't move to boca if you're not
[ __ ] moving cans of money oh no no
that wasn't the case at all no
spoke was a a wealthy area but we
weren't we had more money in ohio
actually than in florida we broke ties
like the money was gone like we
we we he sold his stocks he had enough
we had enough money to move and buy it
stocks stocks in the company wow that's
good so that means it was a publicly
traded company
that's not what it means okay
yeah what was it on the nasdaq let me
get a couple of bitcoins and two cans of
mushrooms
but one of the big at the time one of
the big uh clients was stouffer's
food and uh government contracts also so
that's where [ __ ] yeah a lot of times
my grandfather did well and my father
was a big part of the reason they were
successful but they couldn't get along
and as a result like we moved to florida
and we didn't have money in florida
we i just was home visiting my mother i
got coveted went to go visit her and we
went to the oh we lived in a condo
and it was all of us in this small condo
yeah so
we we grew up very like working to
middle class sure
and how many brothers and sisters did
you have how many older brothers older
brother who's
a musician uh younger sister nice so it
was the three is in there as kids
yes did you have to share a room with
your brother with my brother bunk beds
at first
that [ __ ] breeds wrestlers i don't know
why yeah cause the lights go out and you
start [ __ ] putting each other in
headlines
it's really fun as a wrestler to try
moves at home on your phone yeah it's
really great
it's a fantastic [ __ ] but i gotta say
the thing about football is at a young
age because there's been a lot of
backlash about
kids playing contact football contact
football
is i understand the concussion and the
brain injury part of it
but it's really i think good
for people i do it i agree i mean
the kids uh now i went back to my high
school a few years ago and they're like
don't hit during the week i'm like
do you know how much this would have
changed my
experience of playing sports it's like
we we hit every
day except for the day before the game
thursday and it's like there's something
about that contact
that makes you humble of course and it
really does it humbles you and it kind
of changes your perce it gives you a
a respect for everybody else that you
wouldn't get if you're playing a
non-contact sport
yeah i totally agree it's like being
punched in the face yeah
we always say this because you know
what's on the other end of that it's
like yeah i could get [ __ ] laid out
going across the middle here you got to
keep your you know
right keep your head on the phone i
think that's missing in our not to get
preachy but
it's missing in our society today with
twitter with all the social media that i
don't think we're evolved enough to do
it's like people just saying stuff
flying
around saying whatever with no kind of
like oh this is
consequences to it yes you know what i
mean i totally agree whereas in the
hitting
scenario it's like there's consequences
you run full speed at a guy
you're going to feel it he's going to
feel it you're both there's something in
that
and maybe i'm not articulate
articulating it very well but there's
something in that that's
very good for society versus when you
could just rip off a tweet and say
i don't care yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] this guy yeah yeah yeah
of course if there's a threat of getting
smacked in the face you're not gonna
[ __ ] run your mouth at somebody right
well there's there's a one it's it's
it's very similar to to comedy in this
the when you buy it's like there's
consequences
to your choice right like if you decide
to go you're like i could get hit i
could but whatever it is it's like
there's an immediate consequence right
when you're on twitter or whatever it's
like [ __ ] you i'll say whatever i'll do
whatever right
and that constantly over and over
conditions you conditions you to be like
i don't give a [ __ ] about whatever it
conditions you and it's bad for you
yeah it's bad for you as a person to to
to
to do that and to not think about uh how
you're affecting other people or
how you're just like hurting other
people and you're like oh this is no big
deal
yeah i told you did you coach at all i
coached a little bit when i was t i
taught
uh i got my degree and uh so i'll
continue with the
because let me tell you i'm actually 100
years old a long story
i just want to tell you jacked up right
now i would start doing [ __ ] wind
sprints for you
right now to where mcdonald's what are
you talking about he's got the juices
flowing we're talking about pop warner
football
corner football baby you always [ __ ] on
me if i bring up red singer football
yeah you're doing it like in the car
we're on a [ __ ] interview podcast
and we're asking about his childhood
we'll we'll just be driving down [ __ ]
third
hurry i wanted to tell you about the big
game against lansdale catholic in the
fall in 94.
shout out to zephyr mitchell for that
big six um
okay back to boca so so i graduate
college penn state moved to philly
uh with a girl that i was dating in
college she was in law school
and we lived together for three years we
break up i'm by myself
and uh while while i'm working i started
working but then i was like i started
working with kids with behavioral
problems
okay i worked at a place called glenn
mills schools which is no longer in uh
we used to play them in the cross yeah
they're very it's adjudicated kids from
all over the country so instead of going
to lock up they send these kids to this
school yeah
individuals tough tough kids but it's a
the the beauty of the school was it was
a narrow scope
of kids like they didn't take pyro
pyromaniacs
they didn't take sex offenders it was a
very it took aggravated assault
kids who dealt drugs not addicted to
drugs but were drug dealers
um they took a certain uh car thieves
they took a certain kind of
narrow scope and they really did a good
job of with the parameters within the
parameters of them yeah
so they did a good job i worked there
for a year and then i was like okay i
don't want to work shift work
anymore and i don't want i want to be
more uh versatile than just being
in this program even though it was a
great program
so i went back at night and got a
master's degree from cabrini college
shout out mother cabrini got her statue
she got a statue erected to her
finally um and uh we've all been waiting
we've been waiting i mean i don't know
if you guys it's about time she got her
[ __ ] due
according to the newsletter catholic
weekly we have been waiting a long time
my mom forwarded that to me yeah
um so she uh i went to that school and
at five years at night and i got a
certification and master's damn
special education you're a [ __ ]
worker worker baby and then uh
you use the word shift job anymore
that's not that's as
old school as it gets that four to
twelve what are you working third shift
like a breaker boy or something like 12
go get a beer yeah
that's wow damn he's a [ __ ]
sharp guy yeah i got a master's in
special education then i taught for five
years in public schools
i went to i i in philly in philly
in northeast philly i taught at woodrow
wilson middle school okay on cotman
avenue
i'm from i was born in the north in the
northeast northeast is great
yeah i love how i don't know the way it
was zoned but northeast high school
i used to like to work out with their
wrestlers sometimes right across the
street from the purple orchid
which is a strip club hilarious
hilarious
zoning flawless up there
you're like a city planner with a sense
of humor you know what i mean
they're not going to get it now it's
going to pay off in a couple of years i
love the northeast i love northeast
philly so
i did that for a year and then uh i i
had a tough time
the breakup happened i got a dui i had
nowhere to live
uh i i didn't know how she was a lawyer
so she was handling my court case but
then
things before us things going between us
wasn't good so she got another she got a
lawyer to help me
to her uh credit but then
i was like i was communicating we were
so on the [ __ ] outs that i just
called the lawyer i was like look just
contact me direct i don't trust i don't
know if she's
sure yeah like i could miss a court i
don't know what's going on yeah so
um that's [ __ ] spiteful that's
vengeance well i got past the uh
dui i got a place i got a job in upper
darby which is
a suburb of west philadelphia of course
and uh
taught there which is one of the best
jobs i've ever had upper darby
darby's nights at drexel hill middle
school and upper glass yeah drexel hill
is nice
it was a nice job great area i did two
years there and then i had a friend at
garnet valley high school
which is farther out that glenn mills
area and uh
and high school so i i went to go teach
high school at garnet valley i taught
there for two years
nice and then i was unhappy with my job
my second year
so um i just resigned
and with no job and uh i was doing tony
and tina's wedding in south philadelphia
oh
my god yeah doing what you guys didn't
you didn't know that one and you booked
me on listen
for the listener tony and tina's wedding
garbage
it's explain it i don't know if they're
doing these i don't know if they're
doing these like around the country but
uh tony and tina's wedding in the
philadelphia tri-state area it's dinner
theater
yeah it's a um it's a fake italian
wedding yeah yeah you can get invited to
you give yourself an invite
did you even have to change your name i
just used your saying
i'm mike vecchio i'm here with tony
hey listen you're a little too italian
we're gonna have to turn it down i can
see that in that audition you walked in
you're hired
that's awesome so i i did what hold on
what because i i'm actually
i played one of the groomsmen for a year
and then i played tony for a while
you were tony yeah i was tony what damn
oh
a little [ __ ] i'm sure i'm sure a
couple of my aunts saw you back in the
day
oh and the guy who played tony was
unbelievable yeah
gorgeously did the dollar dance with him
i'll be honest with you there's all
kinds of different
dances so uh that was
it was really fun because the people
that i was in it with
were great people like we were all we
all had so much fun together i would
just go out
i was dating a girl in south
philadelphia at the time and i would go
down
because i was teaching in the suburbs
right so i would drive down to south
philadelphia on 18th and snyder
yeah and we do the show and then we go
out and i would just get
[ __ ] hammered out at those bars in
south philly yeah
so we're talking mid 90s no we're
talking um early 2000s early 2000s
2000 2001 2002. so i would go to
and there's no social media or any of
that you know and uh
i would go down there i would do the
show get hammered go to my girls
we'd crash and uh because she she was a
classier uh she would like go
to um center city like those uh center
city uh
uh clubs lounges lounges and stuff she
would go and she was like a martini like
she would go hang out with that's how
blue collar is he's like she would go to
center city to one another yeah
one of them fancy fancy lounges
and some of those other martini lounges
and stuff blue martial
yeah she was one of those places yeah
she would go to those places and she
would you
want to shake in your blue martini with
your olive in your drink you're [ __ ]
embarrassing me
and she would always go do you want to
meet me i'm like [ __ ] no you're not
gonna pay 14
for a drink i want to get [ __ ]
hammered down here he's down there like
two street annies with like [ __ ]
for nickel beers yeah i'm getting drunk
with mummers what are you talking about
i just put 20 in a jukebox
i'm here all night i [ __ ] loved it my
friend dropped me off one time his truck
he dropped me off she was right behind
us in her car
ready to park and i was so hammered i
just laid on her windshield
and she was driving to go park she was
driving slow but i was like on her
windshield dude it's lawless down there
like midnight so funny that's great i
had such a good time for those couple of
years and then i moved i moved up here i
was like okay i gotta take a real shot
yeah you know so and that's and then
when i got here
it was uh all about the clubs you know
there was no youtubers there was no
twitter there was no any of this stuff
and there wasn't even that many alt
rooms it was like a village lantern was
still
was running but there weren't that many
just rooms it was clubs
so i would go to the back of the boston
because different comics would run the
boston comedy club
every night right and nights of the week
it was booked a pro shows were booked on
the weekends
and will and talent did urban night on
sunday
which was that was like infamous right
huge man it was that was like
they would [ __ ] pack it out it was
they said it was like i mean that's like
that's like [ __ ] of legend yeah dude i
was trying to get on it because
i could get you know just will and
talent are so nice they're such good
people
that i i approach them to get on it and
uh from coming up at the laugh house as
well there is nothing better than a
[ __ ] packed out [ __ ] show like
that it's unreal
the energy is unbelievable but the
boston was bumping back then and
and if you knew the comics producing the
shows you could maybe get on
marina would produce like a monday blue
monday she did which was tony woods the
show she did blue monday
and um she ran it for a long time and
did a good really good job with it so
you that and then
uh jason sokolov i don't know if you
guys know him he used to do
he'd do like tuesday wednesday and then
tom daddario would do like
thursday and then friday was the club
shows yeah wayne
raita was booking it at the time okay
and then sunday was uh
talent and will so i mean what i'm
trying to say is the landscape was
a lot different up here sure it was like
the whole
mindset to was get on stage as much as
you can but in order to get on stage
you have to hang out like a lot of
hanging out nobody knows who you are
you gotta hang i mean derosa had moved a
year before me or nine months before me
and i knew jay from coming back to
philly
and i knew kurt a little bit but i knew
jay and i knew joe
mostly so um you just tag along with it
yeah i would
joe would like i'm like could i remember
being at that cherry hill rascals
and doing a show with them i was like
opening jay was headlining yeah
and uh kurt and joe had come with jay
and i remember just asking them at the
hang afterwards i'm like can you guys
just at least i understand the way the
business is
so i don't want to be a burden but can
you at least point me in the right way
and you know but they did those guys all
were like oh this he's a friend of ours
from philly so that's
that opens it up of course you at least
have like a little bit of a network of
people who know you oh this is because
we did the same thing we came up from
philly and there was like a gaggle of us
there was like you know from all the way
from like derrick and monroe yes down to
like i think i was the last one
and there was between us there was nine
people had come up so it's like did you
guys work at the laugh house or was it
already closed by then he
started to laugh i did a little bit they
would make me
at that point there was like the raven
lounge and [ __ ] so like there was other
like you know
kind of more mainstream rooms like there
wasn't just helium or that you know you
could there you could get up
but chris cotton rest in peace are a
good buddy chris conn's agreed they
would force me
because i was only doing the you know
the white rooms the mainstream rooms he
was like you gotta come
and he would force me on stage at the
laugh house and i mean i would die
sometimes miserable or you would murder
yeah it would be the greatest you'd feel
like you'd be like i'm
the new king here yeah or you died i
took some losses there too but
there was certain honesty in that room
oh there was real honesty in terms of
like getting your craft together whereas
i have respect for the guys who worked
at that northeast comedy cabaret i know
yeah that's still that was still kicking
friends a lot with a lot of them but i
don't know if you got the same
responses because the crowds i don't
think we're during the week when we
would you know we weren't getting
i wasn't getting on stage on the
weekends yeah like once in a while but
um
mostly during the week you needed a good
read on your jokes
and the laugh house really provided that
yeah it was an undeniable education
and it was you know it was tough and
there was but there was like a family
like the night that i got past there
like was able to start hosting there
right
i'd been you know doing open mics with
weird and like for a little produce
shows
shut out the world shout out to win
[ __ ] win for the
this place would be packed
okay it's talent night all right you've
seen him on the bee
team if you were bombing all right all
right that's it dude he'd have a stack
of paint he wouldn't use the light he
would use a stack of papers and when
people were bombing he would just go all
right all right all right and just
walk up and get them upstairs look miss
mona threw me out of the showroom right
the same night that she passed me to
host there
because mr rod said i could go in and it
was it feels like it was almost like not
like a hazing thing but like uh
you know like a rite of passage yeah
like i didn't ask her or whatever and
i'm standing on the back and i'm [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] in my pants
she walks up she's like who are you lays
into me and then brings me out there and
i kind of stood up for myself
she's like all right we'll see you
thursday night or something like that
nice and gave me the job yeah nice five
years i worked there me cassidy richie
redding
was unbelievable richie redding was
there when i was there yes he had
started out
[ __ ] lightly as a young comic go in
there and he would [ __ ] light that
place up
unbelievable really yeah you know just a
[ __ ] cool sharp funny white guy right
killing right yeah yeah yeah him and
derek
were i remember those guys from there
really yeah derek and
richie had started when i was so we must
have just kind of missed you i think
maybe
like within a couple of years with a
couple years yeah because those guys
had started when i was about to leave
yeah so
but i do remember yeah and monroe is a
good group from philly yeah
i mean strong all the way from you like
your class it's like jay and you
and kurt and then all the way down like
it's there's there's
and the weird thing is it kind of
doesn't matter like racially it was
racially mixed
yeah it was really mixed but there was
no weirdness in it you know what i mean
it was very good that way we all did the
same shows in the same [ __ ] same show
same same people didn't like us the same
people loved us right
we you know after like you know the you
know less and lesser clubs we started
doing our own thing and we were all
mixed in together just doing everything
yeah it's great yeah
look at this [ __ ] time i can shop
here great place to come up though man
yeah it's such a brutally honest yeah
it's like you can get in front of a
larger group of people which is good
and it's yeah and a trash can but it's
brutally odd it's like
if you're not funny you're gonna know
real quick that you're not [ __ ] funny
you know but i i love the beauty of that
place just come back on wednesday sign
up
and uh and try again you know alter it
you know listen to the tape or whatever
there wasn't tape
back then but it's like work on your act
come back and try again and
at that point you know i went through a
breakup it wasn't living on my own i was
like i don't care if i fail
like usually i would be more sensitive
to failure okay but i just didn't care
nothing to live for nothing to live for
nothing to lose baby
but i i kind of operate better when it's
like all right you know get yourself
together and [ __ ] just keep coming
yeah because i don't know about you
that's that wrestler in you that's yeah
that is gonna say that that's why you're
such a you're
if you're if you've got for the listener
if you're not familiar with like most of
you probably are
maybe one of the best joke writers
working today meticulous
nationally definitely one of the best in
the city like
it's insane it's meticulous and you hit
it and it's i think it's that wrestling
it's that blue collar it's the mushroom
canning it's the [ __ ] just go
go work work it's phenomenal i've never
heard somebody say we moved to boca but
i wanted to go back to youngstown
i wanted to go back go back to the
potato favorite john cougar melon camp
fan i don't know
oh i forgot to tell you why that because
i was playing pop warner football
my parents during the summer he's good
baby he transferred he transferred
he red shirted one year they were
sending scouts up like i hear this kid
vecchione can piece a hell of a nose
tackle
all the right moves great movie by the
way with tom cruise
this is one of my favorite episodes of
all time so i'm in florida
i'm gonna keep going with this no i'm
gonna get this out this is the real
reason i i couldn't believe it nose
tackle right
nose tackle but the practices weren't
till six at night
six p.m and and they started in the
summer and
you know how football two a day all that
starts so uh
my parents didn't have the money to send
me to
a summer camp so i went to this summer
camp in the hood
which was which was a good really good
summer camp and they did
they would take you for free if you
didn't have the money and we didn't have
the money
so me and my sister went my brother was
a
a junior counselor at the summer camp
with
that you had to pay to get into so he
got it for free but me and my sister
were put into this
other uh summer camp which there was
nothing wrong with it but they just
didn't
take many trips like the budget was
because you know you didn't pay
so but there was supervision and my
mother
we were too young to be left at home i
was like 10 or something so
left us in the summer camp and it was
just so hot all day
i didn't want to do any of the
activities because i knew i was going to
have practice at night yeah you don't
want to desert yourself so yeah and i
and and you know
he's sitting in the shade car yeah he's
off almost six-year-old worries about
that
he's really listen i can't [ __ ] if i
blow it all out in kickball i'm never
going to be able to [ __ ] do
you got up and dancing here what the
[ __ ] didn't have give me a [ __ ]
protein bar or something
did not have the energy level and i'll
tell you what he's got the soul of like
a 300 year old man
really i'm an old son i love it i
[ __ ] love it the summer camp was a
great summer it was a great summer camp
because
it was called it was called florence
fuller summer camp this is why i want to
know
he's such an old soul and he's so
thorough there's no way he's garbage
because he thinks about everything
he's got everything thought out dot and
his eyes crossing his teeth fantastic
summer camp for financially strapped
people
and i was putting it's a long acronym i
was put in that summer camp
but see that in the brochure can i tell
you guys something
they for every day for lunch they would
give us um dark meat
uh chicken it was chicken yeah it was
it was dark meat chicken um uh
legs wrapped in tin foil and watermelon
well they're fried
that's their service no baked was it a
polish after
school camp fried chicken and whatever
it was it was
baked a dark meat chicken wrapped in tin
foil
and watermelon that's probably awesome
and i did not no to this day i cannot
eat i've been really
dark chicken i'm not i do not like
watermelon because of the way it was
wrapped in tip it was kind of like
sweaty when you would eat it
my skin's crawling yeah i didn't like it
at all and i still can't eat
i would have crushed that but overall a
fantastic summer camp but i just didn't
have the energy to go
and and not to mention the fact when you
play pop warner i don't know if you guys
realize this but i was going to school
different from where i was playing
football so it's like you don't get any
of the
school spirit you don't get any girls
noticing that you're playing
like none of that it's all separated so
nobody in school can't go back and talk
about the blocks you had and
you know yeah no one cares you see that
quack
so when i moved to ohio the football was
attached to the school
it was uh canfield where my mother went
to school one of the nights
and i went to school and it's like
practices right after school there's no
six o'clock practice yeah it's like
everybody was like
uh friends in school you would go play
football together it's like
wow this is like i was loving it eighth
grade was one of my best fears that
makes sense i would want to
i have total sense i would want to do
the same hey chris was one of my best
eighth grade i'd say my single best year
eighth grade
eighth grade oh my god i had a good
senior year too but it was great man
senior year was the best forget about
some people hated their high school
experience
they absolutely hated it and i loved it
i love my high school i loved my i
didn't have
we were like the partiers like we
partied about like you were like
the sports i didn't give a [ __ ] about we
would just like party we're like oh
you see a movie and like they're
partying he's going that's what i want
to do right like i loved i had a blast
but
with everything you're saying i i
recognize and i'm grateful and i know
how lucky i was the environment that i
was able to grow up in and the coaches
that i had
were [ __ ] literally i mean i i
couldn't have been more lucky so yeah we
i [ __ ] loved it i know people had
shitty experiences on that note i'm
grateful i'm grateful for the coaches i
had the teachers
and the people that i went to school
with in both places were unbelievable
like it was really
uh in both places very very good and
that means what are we doing here let me
[ __ ] come
damn it all the difference in the world
man all right i'll be steady qb
one on one i'm steady
[ __ ] i would love for vacuum to lay you
out across the middle
[ __ ] take your head off full pads
full gear
yeah you love it i take a good hit too
i remember getting a [ __ ] nice
concussion in [ __ ] college
and the way we fell into each other the
defensive coach thought i hit the kid
hard
i didn't know my [ __ ] name i just
fell into it the big guy could take a
hit
that would be awesome hey what's up
everybody i want to tell you about our
new
sponsor cushy dreams baby cushy dreams
has
high quality cbd bud and i for one
am a big fan of cbd i started taking
about a year ago to take the edge off
you know what i mean really calms me
down which i like and
i didn't even know you could smoke it
until cushy dreams came along
it's fantastic i smoke a little bit
after a long day of podcasting with the
big man
to help take the edge off because it
gets on my nerves i go home
i fill up a nice bath because i draw a
mean bath you know that about me
i light up some [ __ ] cbd bud from
cushy dreams
and i just let the day melt away and
here's what's great about cushy dreams
it's grown
in the u.s of a baby homegrown 100 hand
trimmed
never machine trimmed get it out of here
cushy dreams takes an artisan approach
everyone is a small batch it has
independent lab testing compliance and
purity
each batch is slow cured to preserve
flavor in the cannabinoids
good night cushy dreams cannabis comes
in both cans
and pre-rolls so they do the work for
you if you're a pod head
so when you open up one of these cans
you'll instantly realize that it's high
quality bud
it's high quality stuff we're talking
about here and plus cushy dreams ships
legally to 50 states and to cbd
cannabis that isn't going to get you
high because i don't smoke weed anymore
but i like taking this stuff to take the
edge off
it's easy peasy so if you go to
cushydreams.com and use promo code
garbage
you're going to get 20 off so do it now
back
to the show all right let's get into it
this ah jesus christ i love the i love
an episode though where
[ __ ] 30 minutes 38 minutes and i haven't
even [ __ ] started growing this guy
yet now there's no way
that he's going to be garbage there's no
way but i would like to delve into it
to the meticulousness yeah let's let's
let's look at this way let's find the
level of class
yes find the level of class
all right this is one that i had for you
uh but knowing you know hardcore italian
yes
um i didn't know you your family used to
uh you know you lost out to big big ragu
you know big ragu came in what jar will
you
if you what jar pasta sauce will you buy
today
um you might make it whatever but if you
have to buy a jar if you're
not wait hold on not would you ever
let's start
yeah oh you would yeah because i'm not a
big like
um first of all i don't eat i'm not
eating yeah yeah
but uh um but if i did back when i was
eating it
uh i would do four cheeses was one i
would buy
from classico yeah yeah and then the
other one was rayos
right i got to eat at rails before hold
on rails is like 15
is it worth it it's a pricey jar yeah
it's it's it's good
you think it's worth it really and he's
the becky own stamp of approval it's
very good
he's he's from a sauce family you get
what you pay for
yeah i mean it's fifteen dollars i can't
bring my how did you get a table at
rails who'd you go with
uh mike de stefano de stefano i connect
them with chris but yeah
mike uh mike was a great comic do you
guys watch him i watched his uh the
documentary that the cringe guys or the
yeah yeah yeah yeah
but he was really we're uh close friends
and uh
he called me up i was at the gym i
remember and he was like i want to know
if you want to go we got an extra seat
i'm like
okay dude this is mike i'm going to tell
you this right now
i said listen um why don't you think
about it for 15 minutes
maybe there's somebody who can i i'm
more i actually maybe somebody could
help you in the bit like
call colin yeah and call someone you
know call calling and ask him like
somebody who like who your friends
were all cool with but like somebody
what i appreciate how i would appreciate
it
you know uh because i you know you're
not getting it i'll take you to pizza
that's a [ __ ] classy move right there
but uh he took me and uh it was
[ __ ] fantastic for the folks out
there that don't know rails is this
ultimate exclusive italian restaurant
that there i mean
there's like five six tables right and
then you know
all controlled by mob cap yeah yeah and
you know in the heyday it's madonna's
over here this one's over there de
niro's over there
and to go to that restaurant is [ __ ]
damn near impossible yeah yeah
mike this definitely mikey d mikey d was
the man
he was the man one of the guys from his
neighborhood had a uh
table there so and then so we all sat
there and ate and it was
uh it was fantastic i don't think i've
ever heard the
the pass it off to go ask someone else
that's a [ __ ] home run
if you asked me to go to popeyes right
now
no because i know how valuable i know
but still that's like you're thoughtful
that's
your very thought that's thought out a
bunch is pretty good yeah
well i didn't want him to like not think
about it and be like ah you know
you know that's a [ __ ] class act move
yeah nowadays comics would be slitting
each other's throats
dude i went to get on the list i would
step over your dead body
but for people who don't know rayo's
closed on the weekends
is it it's closed on the weekends even
before the pain i was like closed on the
weekends only open during the week
and everybody except our table was
[ __ ] hammered
they were hammered yeah i love it
because we were sitting with guys that
other guys were coming over and giving
respect to
and um and they were like everybody was
a friend of ours who was like
everybody else everybody was hammered
except for us yeah i was like i want to
be
like sober yeah i want to be lucifer i
want to remember all of us yeah
damn i would drink just out of nervous
energy i'd have to be like no i'd be
scared they thought we were cops or
something like that
because we get that now we can't walk
into a [ __ ] bodega
well first of all he dresses like the
world's worst undercover cop
he's typical this is good for him right
now this is good he's typically in a
[ __ ]
huge hawaiian button-up that doesn't
close so great
camo shorts and he walks in we i walked
in to buy a pack of cigarettes last
last week out front of here we walked
into two different bodegas and i walked
into the back to get a bottle of water
and he stayed up front and he goes
hey how you doing today man like he's
making small talk with the guy and i'm
like
what this is just so you came up with a
weird vibe dude so then i get the water
i go in a pack of marble lights and he
goes no no we don't do that here any
trucks from florida coming up
he refused to sell me cigarettes at a
bodega and we walked into another one
and
i said stop you're acting weird don't do
it walked in and asked the guy hey how
you doing before
he refused to sell me cigarettes so i
said you got to walk around the block
or something you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
blocking me dude
he goes in with like you know you you go
in with mayor [ __ ] vibes and people
get
this is new york this ain't [ __ ] blue
bell or wherever the [ __ ] you came from
kevin's not a big fan of mine
i'm a big fan of yours in small
increments this is more of a work not
when he's not smoking
yeah exactly i'm trying to get my i'm
trying to get my hands fixed dude and
you're over here [ __ ]
blocking me i'm surprised you would even
entertain the idea of
of a jarred pasta sauce to be honest
with you you do cook right
i do cook but uh like i eat different
now i don't eat i gotcha at all so
but um i imagine when i did eat i was
big on i wasn't all make it from scratch
yeah yeah okay so yeah of course it's
awesome
that's a whole process for a bunch of
people or a lot it's it's it's
my mother does that and when i go she's
probably throwing it it's she throws
down there she really [ __ ] does i
really appreciate it now
but last time i was home i was like i
was eating this way which is clean
i didn't i had the option for pasta and
i was like no you know what let's just
go sausage and peppers
which is delicious also because we took
the provolone and wrapped it in the
provolone
oh buddy i've never even i never even
thought
with the olive oil you know it's soaks
in olive oil when mom does it right man
out of the park it's a killer i imagine
the apartment is meticulously spotless
no
really my apartment is not really no
because me and dan live together me and
um
soda yeah and uh i love the guy i love
he it's the best it's really the best
and um
we just have a bunch of stuff that's
accumulated from over the years
you know shows and what and whatever and
just stuff that so there's a table
you know uh my girlfriend uh actually
comments about it it's like anytime i'm
like
hey can you put your stuff over here and
she's like what the whole table full of
yeah
so we have a table of all of both of our
[ __ ] on it
and uh but it's it's it's neat but
there's a we've accumulated a lot we
really have to go through everything
yeah
make your bed every morning yes [ __ ]
do that you have to
call that that's jordan peterson i don't
know if you guys know that
jordan peterson that's uh make your bed
i mean i made my baby the admiral
whoever it was that made the
commencement speech no that's the guy on
he's been on rogan a bunch of times yeah
a psychologist who's like uh
the 12 rule he has that book 12 rules
for life he's uh
whatever controversial for some reason
yeah it was the canadian guy that made
the he was a canadian professor and
gotten some said he wouldn't say the
gender pronouns he refused to say
but um but he his book is great and he
do you refuse to say gender pronouns
i will call you guys both z answer
yes sir that that's ridiculous but um
he's fantastic
and i'm a big fan of reading his book
and uh his book is all about that about
you know
you don't have that much it's like just
take care of take it up make it it's one
of those things you've accomplished
something before you've even left the
room
it's like same with a cold shower they
say if you do a cold shower in the
morning
you have a common moment the hardest
thing that you're probably going to have
to face is that fantastic three minute
cold shower it's all momentum too it's
like
i get even if you get up to pee like
charge my phone because i don't like to
charge it overnight because it
wrecks the battery so i'll charge it
i'll charge the phone go pee come back
i'll wake up um and the phone is already
charging it's like we already have one
yeah
the ball rolling down the hill cold
showers are great if you're crashing
really hard too
get [ __ ] jolt yeah yeah this'll jump
if you were
so inclined to bring such activities
this is going to be a long shot but if
you ever owned any inflatable furniture
mike
inflatable furniture a chair a couch i
don't own that much
first of all let me just say that i
really am dude this guy
sleeps with a go bag he's got a couple
of passports a roll of [ __ ] five
grand
i got a friend in florida uh he went to
west point and i grew up with him and uh
he's great he's a great guy he went to
west point and he's a corps of engineers
guys
super like he's a great dude he lives in
miami as a house
and his house is the house he's cuban
and
his immigrant grandmother and
grandfather came in they had 16 kids in
the house
he owns the house now it's just him and
it's just he
keeps it simple on purpose yeah i mean
he has
he has the money to do whatever he
doesn't like that he keeps it simple and
he doesn't have a flat screen has a
regular tv
he does that purposefully and i i love
that wow
yeah i pro keep it easy keep it simple
stupid
keep it simple so inflatable furniture i
would have to go now
okay let me ask you this yeah you're
pouring something down you have
you have a garbage disposal no okay
perfect all right so
uh if you're washing dishes or whatever
and a little bit of food collects
in the in the thing right will you a let
the water run and use your finger to
smoosh it down
or will you scoop it out and throw it
away properly i don't scoop it out we
have one of those drains that catches it
and i'll take it
and then i'll i'll bang it bang it out
in the garbage and then put it back yeah
i just got one i just moved places and i
finally got one of those things
that's a classic i feel like a [ __ ]
rockefeller with it i do the finger and
smoosh everything down
okay we could tell i also pour bacon
grease down that thing do you
yeah doesn't that [ __ ] up your drain
yeah it's for like the whole building
everybody
everybody below you you're clogging up
their holes maybe for the next guy just
moved out
sucker you ain't getting a deposit
either
do you well do you eat bacon on your
current diet yes what do you do with the
bacon grease in a new york city
apartment it's tough
what do you do with it i'll pour it in
an empty can or a jar or something and
then throw it out
separately well you throw it out
immediately or we let it build up for a
couple of days or a week
i might let it i might let it sit there
yeah i might let it i'm not gonna throw
it away right away because if i make it
again something again
i might need to of course would you ever
use that grease to cook
i thought about it but i've never done
it okay yeah interesting
okay have you ever owned a sopranos or
goodfellas poster
i think that might be a yo no because i
have
i have um in my room i i gotta
obviously redecorate i got a lot of
problems in there but um i can see
you rolling around philly in [ __ ] the
early 2000s baggy jeans
a royal blue butt a pair of carpenter
jeans royal blue button down a t-shirt
and a [ __ ] leather jacket [ __ ]
with that exact haircut
this was a popular haircut in south
philly so perfect in the early 2000s
that is the south philly south philly
special
um i have a tony antinas poster
okay well that's that's uh yeah are you
on it are you that's work
is it isn't it that's just work is it
you and the are you oh that's it
giving her like a dip um tony and tina's
poster
i have a um michael corleone um in
sicily
okay uh i haven't seen it
he's got a [ __ ] he's in sicily
[Laughter]
before he asks the father his before he
tells the father his true intentions
oh okay what do you mean when they're
sitting in front when they're sitting in
front and the father gets offended
so that's it's that from that scene and
so that and then i have a raging bull
which de niro is just like with his
fists up like this poster john f kennedy
then i got jimmy hoffa's ashes a picture
of dennis franz in the bathroom
corleone um raging bull jake lamotta
and then um brad pitt from fight club
wait are these all in your apartment
right
now on right now as we speak that's free
unfortunately my friend
we're gonna have to put that in there
are they framed
yes that's even worse they are framed i
got them framed
better um tape like half rich you know
like fantastic
brothers poster in college yeah at least
they're framed but
yeah italians love italians man you guys
just love each other i know
but now i look at it and i go this whole
thing is hacky yeah
it's pretty accurate but i like them for
i like the calm coolness of uh
corleone the uh yeah well that's
different because it's like it's also
it's a shot of
uh you know a cinematic it's a cinematic
shot of a world famous movie that's
understandable
is it the cover nero it's a it's a movie
that's
i i guess but it's such a common movie
it's almost like when somebody says
something that's hack it's like
it's just even if it's like it's just
such a good it's such a thing that's
well known
yeah so i'm not saying that godfather is
an unbelievable movie yeah all the
series but
it's like kind of hacky like an italian
guy uh de niro
uh pacino the pope well ed norton's a
little different so yeah that's a
curveball you said you had what's brad
pitt was there
oh brad pitt yeah yeah and went in in
the basement
of flight club but again early 2000s
yeah that was all class right there yeah
people would think you were rich like
holy [ __ ]
do you own i love that movie by the way
what fight fight club oh it's fantastic
i [ __ ] love it and not for the
reasons that most people
like like not for the fighting or any of
that big soap guy
i'm a big for this spell
that's
i know exactly what you're talking about
i make and i sell so can i sell so
but it's this it's the psychology of on
the underlying psychology sure yeah i
love it
yeah and meatloaf was great meatloaf was
funny he was the first concert i've ever
seen shout out to meatloaf
forget about it i don't know why my mom
took me to that but i loved it that
played ever at every [ __ ] summer
party that played [ __ ] for hours
my parents and their friends are all
getting all juiced up doing god knows
what that god knows who won doing
anything for love
that's why he gets the big bucks printed
as a credit
print it as a clip that is a hot one do
you have any dvds now do you have
any dvds we have a whole house can you
see them when you walk they're like
displayed yeah
do you use them are you guys watching oh
that's dan that's dan's thing i don't
know
up his spot okay well he's trash we had
him oh okay he's pure trash yeah i'd be
upset if he didn't own the
dvd's he has him and i have him like in
boxes but i don't have he hasn't
displayed
that's another level thing where you go
this is look how much money i got or
whatever
and then he puts his pro wrestling dolls
on top of it we were talking we just
talked about that as well with him you
ever see friday i got it right here you
want to check it out
but uh dan i know uh you said he's trash
but he's a specific brand of like
western college sure yeah yeah yeah that
flavor to him
he was very very 90s trash he's a very
like product of the not like you know
90s kid yeah yeah let's take the uh
let's take the roommate situation see if
we can
can exploit that a little bit we might
we might be onto something here with the
[ __ ] part oh and i have a picture of
uh jesus
i haven't seen you because you're a good
[ __ ] kid mike that's why with the
sacred heart that my mother gave me
and then there's another picture of
jesus and i have a joke about this but
inside the picture of jesus with just a
prayer
oh that's frightening so it's like it's
a little ominous yeah
worry about how much might happen my
joke is if this guy's
[ __ ] wound a little too tight if
jesus was on facebook
it's like his profile resurrection
background photo
jesus's cover photo yeah uh is there any
tv trays in this apartment
uh you know what i do have a tv tray
it's um a wooden
one though it's not that cheap not the
cheap plastic one it's it is wood do you
use it
i'll use it to shoot like videos if i'm
keeping something on it but i won't use
it to eat
where are you eating most of your meals
when you're home alone a bathtub
uh kitchen and at the kitchen table
there's a kitchen we have a desk that
over that is as high so i'll eat the
meals
so you're not sitting there watching tv
like a dirt bag with the with the tv
tray and a bottle of hot sauce on it
you're eating it in the kitchen
eating in the kitchen are you watching
tv while you're eating i'll watch the
computer
i can't lie i will watch that's my
computer it's fine still 20 20. [ __ ]
discipline right there
i would eat in my bed if [ __ ] i was
by myself
all right this is this has been a hot
button issue well they got two hot
button issues uh
i want to know this being in a roommate
situation do you brush your teeth in the
shower
i thought you're going to ask if we were
proud boys
[Laughter]
we are both proud boys but we are not in
the organization proud boys excellent
um go ahead i'm sorry brush your teeth
in the shower no
no right it's disgusting i just never
thought of it i never thought of doing
that
like would you today go home and try it
out tonight no i won't do it that's
gross for you
it's not gross it's just it's just i
never learned those routines and i i
don't see a reason to
i'll shift routines if i see benefit in
it sure but uh well people say because
you guys are telling me to do it doesn't
mean i'm gonna
you know give me a great [ __ ] answer
i've never learned those roots well that
goes back to it
it's under you're not supposed to be
brushing your teeth in shower because
i've never seen a toothbrush commercial
or a toothpaste commercial where they're
in the shower brushing their teeth
they're always at the sink like a
[ __ ] gentleman well i'm making it now
yeah why don't they do that because
you're not supposed to brush your teeth
in the shower it's disgusting
i don't know we'll talk about this the
fbi is a sham
the fda is a sham it's the ada
associated with dennis of america
four out of five so that you can um
brush your teeth and then you brush your
four out of five space four out of five
man this guy's got punchlines but it's
like how do you masturbate then
that's what's like i gotta brush first i
know maybe use a you know electric
toothbrush too
that goes down in the shower that's
acceptable is that where you do your
business
masturbation yes no not in the shower
not anymore i mean when i was really
young maybe sure and there was nowhere
else i'm big into wet work myself
really really still yeah but i will tell
you this uh
uh to that i stopped watching porn
you're in a healthy relationship that
typically it slows it down or was it a
choice
it was a choice wow like that's it i'm
done uh i think it's bad i
i don't they've done studies but uh i i
think it's bad for you
if you fly too close to the sun a little
bit yeah it does something to your
endorphins where
it activates your pleasure cells too
much and
it's not good i agree i don't know and i
i've it's not a moral judgment on people
who do porn
or people who watch porn jesus watches
yeah a little tough
you want to take a walk or something huh
i don't get the face jesus go look at
the car will ya
yeah but i find it to be almost it's too
stimulating no i i totally agree
especially when you're like looking and
you're looking and you're looking you
know i'm like what am i doing if i had
one of these when i was 12 i would have
you know
like now i'm going through 9 000 videos
yeah i think patrice had a joke about
that where it's like you need more and
more depraved
things to get out yeah of course and
that's i don't know the science behind
it really but that's just not a good
sign yeah that's a sign of addiction for
sure for sure
yeah my endorphin system is all [ __ ]
up
really you seem like you got a good head
on your shoulders man
getting into some weird [ __ ] all right
let's see here uh and also
uh if you go out to a restaurant and i
know you the diet or whatever but
pre-diet
if you went out to a restaurant right uh
hold on if you're going where you're
going with this this has been
devastating civil war is splitting
on social media people are [ __ ] going
crazy about oh wow yeah but i
i i am confident and i know you're
classy that you're gonna you're gonna do
the right thing and answer the right way
good good kevin i'm sorry
you're out you're out to dinner yeah
will you and there's leftover food will
you do a doggie bag and take on the
leftover food
yeah i will and first of all i object to
the [ __ ] the way you
you you see the way you got a leading
question a hundred percent they're
called doggy bags get your ex-girlfriend
on the phone right now
that was [ __ ] a leading question why
it's leftovers it's not a doggy bag
it's trash is what it is if we're
cutting the [ __ ] if we're splitting
hairs here
be can you believe this do you believe
uh he doesn't believe in leftovers you
don't believe in taking leftovers i i
just think that's
i'm not a big waste guy sure i finished
my meal at the
thing i very rarely have meal
food left over i can't force i was i was
grew up with eat everything on your
plate and since
i've learned that that's wrong that's
the wrong way yeah so
if there's food left over there for me
there rarely was
but uh i would take it home just because
i'm against wasting it sure
now do you have it that night later on
probably yeah i would have nice
would you put it in the fridge or would
you let it sit out so it keeps like its
natural freshness
um natural freshness you know what i
mean like you know the natural bacteria
well you know what
airborne stuff the covid
does this have covet on it i would i
would let it sit out but i always with
uh
when you let it sit out it's almost like
you're admitting to yourself that you're
going and that you're going to eat it
again and foregone conclusion
also like we live in a world where he
has leftovers what are we talking about
well we haven't had a leftover since 92.
that's not true it is at tony d's last
week i [ __ ] brought him a whole bunch
of muscles order
ordering an additional entree to go is
not take home
cut the commercial prank but uh leaving
it out
when you put in the fridge you're like
okay i'm gonna delude myself and think
that i'll eat it tomorrow and then you
go to the fridge and see
i don't even skip that because it's
better if you just leave it out then
around 11 o'clock you [ __ ] throw that
in the microwave you don't have to get
it warm you don't have to go from cold
to warm
just like you're right at the restaurant
mikey it's [ __ ] awesome yeah but
uh fasting is like i gotta get you i
gotta i'm
it's unbelievable i've tried i've i've
tried it and i never
clicked i lost a bunch of weight doing i
lost like 55 pounds doing
no sugar no grains back in the day i was
able to keep most of it off but and then
i tried and i'm gonna face i just can't
just doesn't click for me it's not
if i just discipline yourself be like
six o'clock i'm gonna eat one last time
and then i'm not eating i don't give a
[ __ ] what happened yeah i just get you
gotta boss yourself and be like i'm not
[ __ ] eating after you've got that
discipline and
i'll tell you what it's like it's hard
as a nail i can't
[ __ ] believe it dude i can't believe
how well you look great
it's bad on my energy level yeah like
i'm i'm sharing it with anybody who will
listen to me
i might have to i might have to take you
up on i would love to see my tune
somebody up
like from like across the street i bet
you'd be nice
i bet he does this after he knocks him
out
he shoots his cuffs real quick hey mikey
i'm not that guy at all i'm a very uh
yeah you're very calm
i'm a common loving guy yeah you are
you're a sweetheart
i bet you throw a good gut punch
it's that one where this one this hand
goes up
know what i'm gonna do
then like the barstool guys who were
friends with kfc and feidelberg they all
picked it up and it's been like an
ongoing war now
and i just want to if you take leftovers
you're trash i
i it's a trashy thing i don't think
you're trash it's a trashy thing to do
one because here here's my points of
view and people say it's so good i'm not
saying it's not good
kfc i like copper i like hot dogs in the
microwave just because i like it doesn't
mean it's not trash
it is a trash thing to do because i
think if you didn't
take it home it's a literal trash it's
going in the garbage there's no other
use for it
and it's like even if you didn't finish
it they're called doggy bags it was
supposed it started
first of all started a depression to
take food home to your dog that's
literally how it started
i've done some research
[Laughter]
i'm taking it home from my emotional
support animal
if you take it home dude if it's a thing
you can take home for you or your dog
it's not like it's not a classy thing to
do that's a decent point
but i i just i look at it from a waste
sure and i understand i don't give a
[ __ ] if it becomes illegal i'm [ __ ]
still doing it i'll pay that right now
yeah buddy you're no [ __ ] what are
you you're no way i'm leaving a [ __ ]
ever plate of carbonara [ __ ]
for some bus boy to get his dude i was
never a big carbonara guy my
my wife my wife turned me on to it
she's german so it's all the italians in
germany
and like so their pizza places are all
like actual it's like a bacon egg and
cheese but without
man it's got the egg it's got the
[ __ ] oh
good night i thought you were talking
about the true tv show carbonero
he's a magician with pasta the things he
does i'll tell you that
is this your meatball big nathan to you
guys
i like it that's good all right here i
think i only got one or two more maybe
i think he's pretty bulletproof you're
gonna find maybe one or two things
but i mean what are we doing this guy's
[ __ ] mm-hmm
here's one um when you're eating yeah
okay
are you a bite and sip guy or you eat
the meal have your drink
what do you stand on uh i gotta say that
um i only drink black coffee
black coffee herbicide i don't drink
when i eat
turn the lights off i i don't know i
don't know about that but here's what i
will say i
i eat i and i'm trying to i'm trying to
work on this
i eat [ __ ] fast i eat really fast and
i don't i don't drink water until like
after i'm
i'm trying to be um that's that steel
country i'm trying to be more of a
conscious eater like
take a bite you know how they they teach
you like 25 times or something they say
they teach it at a fat camp it's like
um what did you eat no my father my
father was
real heavy okay and they taught him
different strategies like eat with your
non-dominant hand
slow it down slow it down chew 25 times
take a sip of water put the utensils
down and sit there for a second and just
be at peace with it
like really tasty appreciate it as well
i appreciate the food taste the food
swallow the food
sit there for a second let it hit your
stomach like i would just eat like
and it's called conditioning of being in
a family where my mother would put the
food down and we'd eat like [ __ ]
animals
after we prayed
shout out to jesus amen
yeah i'm i'm you're hitting a lot of
bullets with me that's exactly what i
did we got to get you on [ __ ]
you got to get you on intermittent
fasting or at least [ __ ]
dude you could definitely if you
wrestled you could definitely do it or
the name of that camp where i can get on
that dark meat chicken that's what i'm
talking about
after the school program go to the other
one sir how old are you
[ __ ] tackling kids you got any thighs
um
wow all right i got what's your current
ringtone
that's just the regular what came with
the phone class sleep with a fan on you
directly on you no how many pillows are
you using
if any i'm using uh an orthopedic
and then another one so two are you
snuggling the one or is it between your
legs
snuggling it hmm crazy but not garbage
no i'm a snuggler too yeah when i call
it my husband
what's that all about snuggle the pillow
but can't apparently you know
you think my girl actually asked me to
snuggle more like i can't do it with
i can't just the legit not it's not
emotions but i just the logistics of
snuggling another person that in the
heat
yeah my pillow doesn't give off radiant
heat you know what i mean yeah
that's got to be something i guarantee
if people weren't doing that [ __ ] 40
50 years ago there's no way [ __ ] guys
that fought in normandy were snuggling a
pillow at night
that's that's something with how are
they sleeping though probably on their
backs [ __ ] straight up like this
way i would imagine you with one eye
open that's how my dad sleeps
you standing up in front of a foot
locker that's what i'm picturing
all right katie you go to bed i got
watch
like smoking and katie sleep back back
he's got a thermos a coffee
see she sleeps like she's disturbed by
everything though so if uh i would have
this screen on
my phone or something and she would like
we would we got into
numerous arguments about that at the
beginning of the pandemic yeah like she
can't sleep if there's any noise
any luck any kind of [ __ ] light
anything and it's like me i would go to
sleep with like
a full boxing match going on yeah oh
yeah it doesn't matter
i could i've fallen asleep at eagles
games before like it doesn't matter to
me
i can go yeah did i remember the first
the first time i went
up with that ketamine in you yeah
i bet you did the first time i went to
my uh now wife's house
she had blackout curtains and an eye
mask and i was like this girl is psycho
she needs complete complete complete
blackness stillness no
lights same thing with the phone right
it's a [ __ ] movement
any kind of movement it's like a problem
can you collect anything you have a
samurai sword in your apartment
yes you do well no it's not mine it's
dance
dance ice cream series of uh
moving on and uh knives um have you ever
gone to myrtle beach for a vacation
no you travel with a full-size pillow no
take your shoes off on an airplane no
will you take food onto an airplane
yes i i used to do that i don't do it
now i just fast
okay i'll just fast but um uh i would
take
because i couldn't i was doing keto and
i couldn't eat the snacks or
dietary restrictions is different yeah i
would take it as a dietary
i would get like bacon yeah i would get
the bacon there and take the bread off
and i would take it on the plane and eat
it
oh really that's pretty pre-coping
pre-covered that's tough that's smelt
but can i say something in my defense
about how do you hold it do you eating
it with a knife and a fork
no i wouldn't take it with my hand wait
a minute yeah this is going to speak to
trash but i would just
savage but i i i i'm not pushing the
next episode we just found a well here
look into the camera guy's ready to
[ __ ] start ladies and gentlemen of
are you garbage mr vecchio
turn the heat up a little bit i'm not i
i'm not trash
i'm a utility guy though okay if
something works for me and i find
benefit in it
then i will do it to that end but i have
to say that i'm not trash
but some of the things that might seem
like trash
because i find utility in them it's
functional it's functional yeah i get
that and it's going to benefit me
overall which is trying to rise to a
higher level
which is the exact opposite of trash
yeah so thank you for letting me make
this statement
there might be a couple of united flight
attendants that might say different i'm
thinking that right now
we got vaccion in 32 b [ __ ] scorpion
down baconators again
i actually am the burger king
forget about it uh i think i got
one more how do you clean a public
toilet seat
if you're going you got to do a number
two right you're jammed up i get it's
not an ideal situation right
it's relatively clean there's no like
big okay
markings or so or anything what do you
do you have a problem with doing a
number two in public no
okay uh functional um
i'll take the toilet paper i'll take a
bunch of it i'll wipe it down
and then uh that little crack in the
middle there
i don't want my penis not that it's huge
but i don't wanna accidentally touching
that 100
so i'll clean that last put it in the
toilet flush it because i don't know
where that water's been
i need fresh water and then i'll go i
agree and then i'll flush i'll flush
immediately or halfway through it if
it's
um more of a long version
to respect the other people yeah i do
the same thing but i take it an extra
step which i've been informed now is
is is a trashy move is i will flush the
toilet a couple of times
take all that toilet paper give it a
little dip in the toilet water which i
assume is clean wow because it's flushed
and then give it a wipe yeah but what
about on the outside of the yeah
i mean obviously there's [ __ ] in the
bowl i know but the water still
the water comes in the side of the bowl
baby right you're not looking at the
at the invisible germs that might be on
the outside of the body
with the water yeah yeah please stop
doing that okay it's covered dude we're
in a pandemic you're using it
you're using [ __ ] water even before uh
covid
that seems that's insane to me he told
he said this before and i let it slide
because we were
we were late in the episode we run out
of minutes but you got to stop doing
that that's nuts i mean how dirty is
toilet water it looks so cool and clean
doesn't it dogs love it they're still
clear
uh you know what's a second out the
middle section there you know where the
where your uh twig and berries go yeah
you can put a piece of toilet paper
there so even if there's there's no uh
you can hang it over
right so there's no no no no you have a
different buffer in case you do you're
on your phone whatever you slip
you're not you know right yeah yeah a
little buffer zone
you wear a robe in the house no no no
yeah
shoes off in the house she's off yeah
yeah have you ever worn a wife beater in
public
uh yes
yeah i do remember that and now i had a
um a short sleeve shirt over it
but i have to say uh in full disclosure
i would t
yes yes yes that's true would you take
it off sometimes and throw the t-shirt
over your shoulder
because that's a real garbage move uh no
because i went to the boat
or something i would because i would
wear it i would keep the shirt i would
take the top shirt off
and just wear the uh beater oh
yeah that's a tough one was the last
time you wore jean shorts
i can't remember okay that's that's the
answer and it's not for any kind of shot
they just don't look good on me what'd
you get in your sats
900 it's all right no it's not what are
you talking about
i got an 870. it's terrible it's a
terrible i thought by around a thousand
was okay
no 900 is pretty low oh really yeah i
mean i
this scoring is different now sure yeah
but we're going off to standard 16 hundo
how about julian mccullough got like a
um almost a perfect score that's really
talking at the seller one night and he
goes yeah well i got like a
1580 or something he might have got a
16. he might have got a 1600.
who else did really good that we've had
on i think gillis gillis was pretty high
yeah gillis was like a 14. he got into
west point you believe that yeah
wasn't it what's that was it amiko
zakamiko was like a 1480 as well
yeah 14.80 is insane yeah
yeah gallows got into west point i did
crazy yeah you need like
football you went there to play play
football got into what i know a couple
guys like that greg warren got into west
point
yeah that's right the guy who beat me it
in uh
the state tournament what was his name
harris brummer yeah you'll never you'll
never
remember because he beat me good he beat
me twice and beat me pretty well
he uh if you're watching this he went to
notre dame
he went to notre dame on a scholarship
and then they shut their program down or
something happened and then he went to
west point
damn yeah he was a smart guy i know i
know his heart as hard as wrestling is
in
in high school and it's and you know
state by state pennsylvania ohio it's
[ __ ] it's insane really tough
but the toughest of the tough would go
to college like a division one college
and they would last maybe a [ __ ]
couple months yeah that's how crazy that
was yeah division one
wrestling doing psycho [ __ ] yeah it's
like we
our high school was really i never
wrestled but we went to i went to
council rock and they were like
notorious state champions every year
so what year what year are you i
graduated in 05.
so there was one family that ran the
[ __ ] that ran it was the rappos
they ran it there was like six there
were six boys
and each one was like tougher than that
i went to like north carolina what'd the
old man do
he was like a [ __ ] real like a
roofing siding company or something
i know the i know the coach still and
perry
whenever we talk about wrestling i make
sure people know who i
was good in high school from where i was
from and then i went to college and i
took my licks in college
and the second year of college i was
like but i was in that i fought hard but
the second year in college i'm like i
can't do this
again this is too much [ __ ] work and
it's crazy
from guys who were just like great and
um
so i make sure but he was i like a
college he was tough and he
was a yeah yeah brad and uh yeah and so
i know
tony fabry who's a friend of mine and um
and those guys are both uh coaches
they're real they were close friends
and um they still are because i went i
do a benefit in uh pennsylvania once in
a while for my friend rob bigley who has
a program okay
in uh in the avon grove avondale area
where's that i don't know where that and
then
fabry coaches for ridley okay and he
also has
a freestyle program so i go do benefits
for both of their programs whenever they
ask me to and uh
those guys are great guys man and uh
council rock is [ __ ] tough
dude they were i mean i didn't know
anything about it and just like every
year was like oh state champion say
champion play second
it was just like they're really tough my
friend rob begley has a program in
avondale that's really
good also you know what i mean so i
guess they're all competing
pennsylvania's like just bread
it's like coffee yeah it's like
pennsylvania like pennsylvania ohio yeah
and these guys all wrestled in college
and they were all americans and stuff so
they're
they're super tough man this guy's a
[ __ ] piece of steel over here
he's class he's class he's got a couple
of garbage traits but the guy's a
[ __ ]
class act over here old school i'll tell
you young kids out there you take a page
out of this [ __ ] guy's book right
he's like a tin knocker
get off your phone i'm that guy get off
your phones
you ain't gonna find it on snapchat get
off your [ __ ] phones
ladies and gentlemen holy [ __ ] mr mike
veki own
the host of no disrespect right here on
the gas digital nominee can i make a
note about
um justin silver who's my close friend
and he's been on the show for two years
he's left it done other to do other
projects it's me myself
uh on no disrespect i'm having the best
comics in the city much like you guys
are
in and i have a lot of fun with them so
uh please
subscribe uh please i'm on youtube and
uh follow me on social media at comic
mic v
and uh just please support no disrespect
part of the gas digital
family and i i'm appreciative to be on
and uh i'm
happy for you guys is your success thank
you i see you guys growing and thank you
we always tout ourselves on no
disrespect as the fastest rising podcast
on the gas digital network
but somebody tagged you guys getting to
5
000 youtube subscribers and tagged me in
it and go
fastest rising and i'm like well i guess
yeah
you guys are you're going to have to
wrestle
but thank you for having me on thank you
yeah it was [ __ ]
one of my favorite episodes of what's up
was i trash no you're what
trash kidding me these kids all clicked
i thought my s.a.t might
ask you a cosign for my new apartment
what are you talking about becky ah
there's a song
that was nice oh yeah thank you guys
teflon don over here yeah that's a nice
drop right there i'd let you do
open-heart surgery on it
right he might need it so you got your
scalpel on you
what do you got guys yes please go check
out mike's podcast i listen i'm a fan
it's [ __ ] great he's so [ __ ] f
as you can see he's so funny go check it
out no disrespect here on the guest
digital network
um as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube
you can subscribe there as well uh if
you're going to sign up for the network
use promo code ayg we make a couple of
bucks you save a couple of bucks
everybody wins
we got some cool [ __ ] coming up that
we're excited to announce we got some
new t-shirts coming up we got some new
we're gonna do some new live streams
some bonus stuff coming up so uh yeah
we're excited
it's gonna be fun gang it's gonna be the
fun end of the year here i wanna just
follow up again
hit you with the [ __ ] one two three
punch make sure you [ __ ] check out no
disrespect and i'm sure most of you are
watching this because you love the show
but if you don't
go [ __ ] check it out mike is
absolutely one of the [ __ ] best one
of the sharpest joke writers
and one of the funniest guys ever and
this was one of the funnest afternoons
i've had yeah
it's been a long time one of my favorite
episodes which one guys we thank you so
much we love you very much thanks for
everybody in the live
chat and we'll see you soon